the dancing didn't go to plan in Crazy
Stupid Love uh no what happened oh you
don't remember well I remember but I'd
like to hear you quick story
when I was about seven years old I was
in gymnastics class and I was on these
parallel bars that are about six feet
off the ground and I was standing on the
top of the bars and the teacher was
holding me by the ankles somehow or
other she let go I put my arms in like
this and I fell six feet to the ground
and I broke both my arms it was the day
before the last day of school anyway I
had internalized this again that's
really important important detail
I really know how to tell a story years
later I know that we're gonna do the
Dirty Dancing lift I don't know however
that I have an internalized phobia of
being you know lifted over someone's
head at the height of about six feet
what do they do right I imagine if a
possum fell out of a tree trying to
scratch your eyes it would be something
similar